I have used one strategy to win
repeatedly across 13 years in business
and also outside of business. And it's
one of the biggest reasons that we had a
$105 million launch for $100 million
money in 72 hours for my latest book.
And I'm going to explain why it's the
highest risk adjusted return move that
you can make to win more in business or
just win more in life. And so if you're
not sure what to do right now within
your specific business, no matter what
industry or size business you're in or
whatever goal you're pursuing, this will
help. I talk about more, better, new a
lot, but I want to dive into the one
that is near and dear to my heart, the
one that is that has made me the man
that I am, which is more. And I want to
talk about that because the fundamental
question every single business owner
needs to answer. And even every person
pursuing any skill or endeavor needs to
answer is why can't I do more? And for
most people, doing more is the answer.
And it's far more common that it is
more. What's very sneaky about more is
that you get to a point and then you
say, "There's no way I can do more." And
at that point is where the big unlocks
in volume really occur. Napoleon had
this really great quote back in the day
and maybe it's misattributed to him but
he said quantity has a quality unto
itself. Meaning like if you do so much
volume you do so much work and in the
military sense if you just have so many
people at some point it almost has its
takes on its own quality of the amount
of work the amount of people the amount
of volume that you're putting into
something whatever it is that you want
to break through. So big picture I
wanted to give you a couple cool little
anecdotes to reinforce this. Some of you
guys know about Shiron. He was on the
live with me. He's our president at ACQ.
I'll tell you two stories about Chiron.
I'll tell you the moment where like we
went from being friends to me being
like, man, I really want him to be, you
know, president of acquisition.com. So,
he was talking about how he was growing
Real. And so, Real was a $200 million
per year business. And he had grown it
from 200 million to 1.2 billion in less
than 3 years. So, like 30 months. And I
want to put that there as a as a moment
for you guys to think about that how how
insane that is. 200 million to 1.2 2
billion less than 3 years. How does he
do it? We're having dinner and he says,
"I just did 260 events in the last 365
days." And I was like, "What do you
mean?" And he was like, "I flew around
and I did every single real estate
event. I spoke on every single stage."
And that's how I generated, you know,
more demand for our uh our platform for
realtors. [music] And when he said that
to me at dinner, I was like, "This guy,
he gets it." Now, we've been friends for
years, but seeing him so tactically
involved in the business and being like,
"That was the thing that took a $200
million business to $1.2 million, just
sheer volume." Now, most people might
hear that and think, "Well, yeah, I
speak on stages one time a month, and
you know, I mean, I I'm on stages all
the time." It's like, no, no, you're not
on stages all the time. You have no idea
what being on stages all the time
actually means. Most business owners
wildly underestimate the amount of
volume one that is required and two that
they are capable of. Your capability is
always higher than what is required. But
the thing is is that you might not know
it yet. And so I've had so many times in
my life that it's become my de facto
operating principle. And so I want to
read you this. This is from my internal
sales handbook that I have for my sales
team. This is the culture of
acquisition.com. Like we ask how can we
do more? Many people say they want to be
in the top 1% or.1% or even 01%. But
saying that has zero bearing on whether
it happens. Achievement comes from
actions, not aspirations. So let's get
real. To be the top 1%, you need to
enter a room of a 100 people and leave
number one. To be the top.1%,
you need to enter a room of a,000
people, like a local high school, and
leave number one. To be the top 01%, you
need to enter an arena of 10,000 people
and leave number one. Think about it, a
stadium. And in a battle to the death in
that stadium, you have to come out on
top. You beat everyone. Not almost
everyone, [music] everyone. And so if
you have the goal to be in the top 01%.
Do you think that you can live a normal
life? Do you think that you can keep the
same friends? Do you think that you can
keep the same hobbies? Do you think you
can stay up late and sleep in on
weekends? Do you think that you don't
have to sacrifice what average people
care about? Do you think that they will
support you when you start to pass them?
Do you think anyone will think this is
healthy, balanced, or logical? No. And
they're right. But it doesn't matter.
When you want to be the 01%, there's no
greater waste of time than explaining
yourself to people who actively don't
support you. It's normal for people to
not understand why you do what you do. I
say this because you cannot make
yourself exceptional and live a normal
life. To make yourself exceptional, you
must live an exceptional life. And an
exceptional life does not always mean
better. It just means that it's so
different that most people will reject
it. And when that happens, you must
reject them as well. Oil and water do
not mix. [music] That is what it really
means to be exceptional. You must become
the exception. So, I routinely get asked
the secret to success. And it just comes
down to this. Number one, get better.
Number two, never stop. If you do only
those two things, you will win on a long
enough time horizon. The problem is
people convince themselves they no
longer want something once they see the
experience of how hard it really is. So
I want to set this expectation for you
as you head off to practice scripts,
mark your calendar, and set your alarms.
The work begins when your motivation
ends. Just win. That's from our internal
handbook that we have at ACQ uh for our
sales guys. And I I want to read that to
you because I want to frame what I'm
talking about today. It seems like a
very simple thing just saying just do
more. But like it's almost become an art
form and something that I have like a
deep passion [music] about which is very
odd to say. But more actually has the
highest risk adjusted return move that
you can possibly make within the
business. The reason more has the
highest risk adjusted return for a
business or for you is that what it's so
hard to to get something to work, right?
Many of you guys have tried anything.
You have a new marketing channel, a new
sales script, a new offer. You try a
bunch of things and then finally
something works. The likelihood that you
changing that thing and that next thing
working is actually statistically very
low. Think about how many different
things you had to try before something
actually worked. [music] And so the idea
is, okay, I have these limited
resources. I can allocate them to take a
risk and roll the dice or I have this
thing that I know works and I need to
jam more into that machine, which is why
the highest risk adjusted return move.
Now, one of the other misconceptions
that I think is that there's a huge
prepoundonderance of people who talk
about optimization, getting as much as
you can for as little as you can. And I
don't think there's anything wrong with
that. The difference is that there are
optimizers and there are maximizers.
Maximizers try to ask the question, how
do I get as much as I possibly can?
Optimizers ask, how do I get as much as
I can out of as little as I can? When
you're looking at returns, maximizers
win. So, what's the difference between
first place, you know, gold in the
Olympics and second in the in the
Olympics, silver, right? A tenth of a
second in a race. But what is the
realistic difference, the real world or
pragmatic difference between being being
the best in the world and second best?
Everything. [music] And so when you're
talking to an Olympian, you're talking
to somebody who be wants to be the top
1% 01% 0001%. Diminishing returns are
still returns. You need to do more
because you're trying to win, not be
cute about saying that you had great
return. And I I say this as somebody who
was a converted optimizer. So, in the
earlier part of my life, I really prided
myself on doing school with as little
work as possible. I was like, "You
nerds, I was like, you guys needed to
study. I can walk in and hit a 91 with
no study." And I'll tell you the story
that really, really changed my life. So,
this guy named Kemp, not he was like,
and hopefully Kemp, you know, maybe
you'll see this. I gave Kemp a hard
time. I did when I was in high school.
And [music] and he was a kid who didn't
catch on to stuff as fast. And you know
what? Kemp's a successful guy now. He's
done great. But this thing happened. So
all of high school I I kind of gave this
guy a hard time. And when we went to go
apply to colleges, I wanted to go to
Duke. So Duke's a top five school in the
US. And I didn't get into Duke. I ended
up going to Vanderbilt, which is also
obviously a great school, but I wanted
to go to Duke. [music] And guess who got
into Duke? Kemp not. And so what was
really interesting is that this whole
time like Kemp would go to study hall.
He'd be like, "Teacher, you forgot to
assign his homework." Like he was that
guy, right? And I I honestly just really
disliked him. But mostly cuz it probably
just reminded me of my own inadequacies
of like I was just unwilling to do the
amount of work that he was and I and I I
shamed him for doing the amount of work
that he did. I was like you have to work
so hard just to try and just try and
come close to me, right? But in the end
he got into the better college. And so
it was this really humbling lesson for
me that none of the colleges cared
[music] that I worked less than him.
They just cared about who had the best
applications and who had the best
grades. And it was this really like very
eye- opening experience. And so when I
went to college, I had a different frame
that I was like, well, I'm not going to
lose. I want to go here and I want to
maximize. I want to study all the hours
of the day that I'm not in class, at the
gym, or at the cafeteria. I'm in the
library. And you can ask anyone that I
ever went to school with, if you ever
meet them. Like that's where I was. I
was in the library 12 hours a day cuz I
was like, well, if I just study more
than everyone, I'll get good grades. And
that worked out pretty good. That's just
kind of a just a little bit of framing
around why I have such a such a strong
affinity for more. Now, I'll give you a
second kind of a little bit more heady
reason. So, I talked about how more is
the highest riskadjusted return. I
talked about how diminishing returns are
still returns. They're still output,
right? The next piece though is that
change [music] has a fixed cost and a
variable reward. All right, so let me
explain what that means. So, I want you
to imagine that this line right here,
ooh, nice and wet. How I [music] like
it. My markers, calm down, guys. Okay,
so I've got this line. This represents
your revenue or whatever your current
level of activity or output is. Okay?
Now, what happens is most entrepreneurs,
they say, you know what, I'm going to
change something. They think they're
going to change something and things are
going to get better, right? You tweak
something, you mess around, you change
your page, change your script, change
your onboarding process, whatever,
[music] right? So then what happens?
Well, if there's people involved,
typically output will go down. You have
to retrade the team. They have to
practice. You know, this variable
affected two other variables you didn't
know about. And this is completely based
on my observation. you typically get
about a 20% decrement or decrease in
performance. What ends up happening
after that is it might not work and then
you stay here or it might be worse and
this goes here or it might get better
and it comes back up eventually, right?
And then maybe you have a 5% higher
output here. This is now your new
baseline. Now, here's the thing. If you
have a 20% guaranteed decrease and you
have the potential for a 5% increase, do
you take that bet? No. But I see
entrepreneurs every day, myself included
for many years, taking that bet over and
over again because I was like, I just
have to get better. I just have to get
it better. But it was a fallacy. It's
not true. Sometime like your business
will never be perfect and you have to
accept that fact. It will not be
perfect. And the thing is is you don't
even know if it's going to get better.
You just aren't sure if it's quote good
enough and so you just want to change
it. You want to mess with it, right? But
the magic is the compounding returns you
get when you do the same thing over and
over again. you get this this depth of
understanding, this depth of skill that
happens with repetition, right? If if
necessity is the mother of invention,
repetition is the father of skill. But
let's look at what entrepreneurs will
normally do. Maybe they'll start seeing
some increase here. But what do they do
next? They say, you know what, I've got
this other idea I have. And so then they
get another 20% decrease. And so they're
constantly living significantly below
their output means or your revenue or
whatever your thing is, below what your
potential is because you're constantly
changing stuff. And I want to be real
with you for a second. If you're a small
business owner, you've got maybe 10,
maybe 20 employees or if you're anything
less than that, then like hear me right
now. The amount of resources that you
have to implement change are so limited.
I pick like one big thing a year that I
do like one. And what happens is when
you realize how limited your resources
are in order to deploy successfully a
new change or a new experiment, what
happens is it forces prioritization. It
forces you to focus on what things if I
only had one thing that I could do this
year. What one thing would I be like
this is the bet I'm going to take? Well,
it certainly wouldn't be a 5% thing,
right? Well, maybe if we write
handwritten cards, we'll get a 5%
increase in referrals, maybe, right? But
given those resources, what else could
you do? And so, when you look at the
whole thing, the whole spectrum, and
this is how I want to I want to frame
strategy for you around this. Most
people think about business strate I got
this from Chiron. I love this. I'm using
it all the time. It's so [music] good.
Most people think about business
strategy like they think about making
dinner. So they go to their kitchen,
they open up the fridge, they look
what's inside, say, "What what what am I
going to whip up?" Right? That's how
they think about business strategy. But
the question that we should be asking
isn't what am I going to whip up from
what's inside the fridge. We should ask
the question, "What the do I want to
eat?" And then go get the ingredients
and go make it happen. When you're
saying, "I'm only going to take one bet
or two bets this year. They're going to
be material." Then it forces you to be
like, "It's got to be worth it." Because
here's the part that no one else knows.
If you change nothing, believe it or
not, people get better at their jobs,
they get more skilled. And so, you'll
typically have 1 2 3% increases that
happen kind of month over month from you
just not changing anything, from just
leaving it alone. And so, this has taken
me so much time cuz I'm a natural I'm a
yes hinge, right? I'm like, let's do it.
Let's shake it up. But why? Cuz the
times I've made the most money in my
life have not been when I've been
changing the most. It's actually when
the business has been really boring and
we're just blocking and tackling and
doing it over and over again. And so
this is something that some people never
learn. Honestly, a lot of entrepreneurs
never learn this. And the hard question,
the hard problem to solve is not the new
idea that you want to try. It's how can
I do more once I've already exhausted my
existing way of [music] doing more. So
for me, the minimum rule is that it's
got to be over 20%, if I'm going to get
a 20% loss, guaranteed, right? Of
course. But I don't even know if I'm
going to get this 20%. Because we have
to analyze this through this is an
investor frame by the way. [music] It's
called uh it's called ICE right which is
impact which is like how big right
confidence is how likely and then ease
is what are the resources required uh
for us to make this thing happen right
now. The perfect world is something
that's gigantic impact gigantic
competence and super easy right that
would be the best type of thing. And so
when we have a riskadjusted return move
we think okay I think this could double
the business. I have super high
confidence and I think it could be easy,
then those are the types of bets we want
to take. Because said differently, if
you know that something could double
your business with one move, why would
you do three? Just because you have this
compulsion to be busy, to mess with your
team, doesn't mean it's what the
business requires. And so, a lot of
people use the business to satisfy their
own ADD, to satisfy their own need for
novelty when the business thrives on
same. It's very rare that you're Kodak
and you need to adjust to the digital
world. It's very rare. We love to tell
these stories, but what we don't tell is
the guy who just said, "You know what?
I've got three levels of my membership
and we're doing a million dollars a
year. How do I 10x my traffic and get to
$10 million a year? And then once I'm
there, what do I need to do to get to
another 10x of traffic to get to $100
million a year?" We don't ask those
questions because one of the fallacies
or the the pains of small business
owners is that uh we and myself
included, right? We consistently think
small. We don't think big enough. And so
let me let me give you an example on
this, right? So let's say and this is
where people get obsessed around
optimization. They get obsessed around
relative returns rather than absolute
returns. So let's say that you've got a
marketing campaign where you put $100 in
and you get call it let's say you get
$1,000 out. Okay? So this is 10 to one.
Amazing, right? Cool. But as soon as you
scale to $200, let's say that you now
are getting uh $61, so you get $1,200,
which is pretty bad. You know, you you
spent twice as much money and you only
made $200 more, right? Most people would
say, "Ah, I I should stop doing this."
The maximizer says,
"We made more money. Net net, we made
900 here, 1,000 - 100. Here [music] we
made a,000. This is still more." And
this is what people miss out on. And so
what happens is when you're a small
business owner, you get obsessed with
these relative returns. And there's a
point where you do want really high
relative returns. You want big high LTB
to CAC and we can get into some of that
stuff. But I want to just put pin this
from a from a larger thinking
perspective [music] because I will see
people stay in these optimization loops
for years. You know, my my optin page
converts at 30%. Right? This is my
optin. And they'll just keep testing it
trying to get it to 35 or 40 or 45%. But
the thing is is like you will never 10x
your business [music] by getting this
30% will never go it will never go to
300%. It's never going to happen. But
you can 10x your inputs. You can do
more.
You can do more and you can send more in
and then that will for sure increase
your output even if your relative return
goes down. If I had the choice between
spending $10,000 and making a hundred
back, 10 to one, [music] or spending a
million dollars and getting $2 million
back, two [music] one, I would take a
million in to get two back every day of
the week and twice on Sunday. Why?
Because it's more. It's still more. It's
absolute returns, absolute output. When
you're thinking about yours, and I'll
bring this to business now, right? I
mean, I've been talking about business,
but like more to business, more
tactical. We have our core four, right?
We have our four ways of getting
customers. We've got our warm outreach,
we've got our cold outreach, we've got
content, and then we've got [music]
paid, right? We have paid ads. These are
the only four things that you can do.
How do we do more? Right? So, from an
ads perspective, we'll start here. More
can simply mean more money. It could
also mean more creative. It could mean
more platforms. All of these things are
versions of more. And so I will
typically do this in reverse order of
risk, right? And so that means that I
think that if I'm going to if I put this
in order for paid, it'd be like, okay,
well, the first I'm going to do is make
more creative. If I have more creative,
I have a higher chance of getting more
winners. If I have more winners, then
I'm going to get better rows, and I'll
be able to scale to more markets, more
avatars, more segments. Great. So that's
the first more I'm going to do. The
second more I'm going to do is I'm going
to say I'm going to spend more money on
ads. How can I take my $100 a day and
spend it for $1,000 a day? What stops me
from doing that? And then third, if I do
step one and step two and I make way
more creative and I spend more money,
then at that point I say, okay, what now
that I built this machine that can
create 10 times the [music] the creative
volume, how do I do this within the
context of Instagram or how do I do this
in context of Tik Tok or how to do this
in the context of X, right? Each of
these platforms. So some of you guys
don't know this, but for the launch, for
the money models launch, this puppy,
right? So for this guy, the reason we
were able to do 105 point whatever
million at the launch is because we
advertised so much, right? So we did I
think 2,000 plus ads before the 6 weeks
out began. We had banked those 2,000 at
2,000. Like count to 100 and then do
that 20 times. And if you count it, it'd
be like, "Wow, this is really boring."
That's how long it takes to count to
2,000. We made 2,000 [music] ads, which
takes significantly longer than counting
to 2,000. And so this is what people
dramatically misunderstand is the amount
of work it takes to do more. Because
then I can say, "Well, my editor, I only
have five editors. They can only do five
ads a day each and that's 25 ads a day
is all we can put out." Well, if I got
to 2,000 ads, do I think that I would
have a higher likelihood of hitting this
big goal? Yes. What would it take? So,
it turned out, we did the math, it took
15 editors. And so, that means that we
had to contract 10 more to do the
editing. What does that cost? A lot less
than $ 105 million. So, we did it. So we
figure out what would it take to get
this big goal in terms of volume and
then what are the resources required to
do that and then is it worth it and most
times the answer is a resounding yes not
a small yes a big ass yes yes and so
[music] then we say then what's stopping
us and the answer is almost always
nothing just do [music] more now that's
how I would attack paid from a more
perspective right from a content
perspective it's the same thing in terms
of scaling editors now one of the
interesting things about doing more is
that doing more is so painful [music]
It's so much work. It's a lot of work to
do more. But that pain forces another
forcing function which is you will try
and minimize how much work you're doing
or at least you will try and get more.
If you have a fixed work like I'm going
to do 100 calls no matter what. I'm
going to do 100 minutes of content no
matter what. What do you think happens?
[music] You think, man, it'd be really
nice if I got higher pickup rates. So
then you start looking at your time and
saying, you know, people pick up more in
the afternoons for my market or they
they pick up really hot between 5:00 and
7:00 a.m. in this particular market,
whatever, assuming you, you know, follow
the law, whatever. You start getting
better. You start looking at the data.
You start saying, go like, if I'm going
to do all this work, I might as well
make it worth it, right? But you have to
put yourself in that pain, that pain of
the lack of leverage, the pain of it
being um inefficient. But you have to
keep it there because what happens is
otherwise is like the weak-minded, the
weak of will do a hundred for one day or
two days in a row and they'll say, "I
didn't get the result I wanted." It's
like, "Duh, of course you didn't. You
didn't do nearly enough." And so this is
why I think people stay small. They get
obsessed with the margin. They get
obsessed with the relative returns. They
get obsessed with the optimization. But
sometimes you just have to do a violent
unreasonable amount of work for an
extended period of time because part of
volume is the consistency associated
with it. We couldn't make 2,000 ads in a
day. We had to make 25 or 50 ads and we
had to do it every single day for
hundreds of days in a row to get to the
point where we could make 2,000. Right?
And that was before we started. We ended
up what with 3,000 2,800. We made 2,800
ads. But we're like, man, I can't I
can't scale my ads past a certain you
don't have enough. We spent 500,000 a
day per day at the end of the launch the
last few days and you can only get to
that level of scale with an equal amount
of scale in terms of the inputs. This is
probably my favorite volume story that I
have because it was so real for me. I
paid somebody who was, you know, way
bigger than me at the time in terms of
uh like content and all that stuff early
on in my career. And I was like, "Hey,
you know, what should I do?" And he was
like, "Dude," he's like, "You just
need," he said, "Pull up your pull up
your LinkedIn." And I was like, "Okay."
He said, "Pull up my LinkedIn." and he
had made 10 posts that day and I had
made one. He was like, "Okay, pull up
Instagram. Pull up your Instagram." He
had made three. I hadn't even made one
that day. And then he said, "Pull up
your YouTube. Pull up my YouTube." And
once we did this two or three times, I
was like, "I get it. I get [music] it. I
just need to do way more." He's like,
"Yeah, dude. Like way more." And so we
as humans often think, "I need to do
twice as much. I need to do three times
as much." We [music] can't fathom what
it would mean to do a hundred times as
much or a thousand times as much. But if
you want to beat every [__] human
being in the arena to the battle of the
death, wouldn't you want to leave no
doubt? Wouldn't you want to make [__]
sure that you were going to win? Because
here's the thing. If you see someone
ahead of you, a lot of people get
triggered by this. They see someone
ahead of them, they throw rocks at them
like because it makes them feel bad at
themselves. I strongly encourage you not
to do that. If someone is doing better
than you, they are better than you
[music] in some way. And in that, you
can learn of them. Real. So, when
someone's doing better, if you're like,
I got to beat them. You look at their
volume, right? And let's say that
someone's doing three times this volume
that you can see, right? What do you do?
Do you do three times the volume? No.
Because now you're just matching them.
You need to do 10 or 20 or 30 times the
volume. Cuz not only that, they're doing
volume that you can't see. You're just
judging on the volume you can see. And
so, if you want to leave no doubt, it's
like, not only if I did the same amount
of work as that guy, I'm always behind.
So, I got to do more work to catch up,
but that's just based on what I can see.
I might have to do more more to make
sure that I accommodate for the things
that I can't see. And so I think I would
ask yourself the question, if I knew
beyond a shadow of a doubt that if I
could do 100 times more than I'm
currently doing, I would hit the goals
that I have, then I would then ask the
question, great, what resources are
required? And then following up to that,
is it [music] worth it? And if the
answer is yes, what's stopping